Hello everybody, hello, hello.
Guys, I... I'm okay.
After last night, I am fine.
I know the waiting room was out very late, like maybe like three hours before the stream started.
But like, I went to bed.
That's... I don't have an excuse.
I literally just... I went to bed.
Guys, I was just really tired, okay?
Yesterday was...
It was an experience and I went to bed.
Also, okay, so the VOD's still alive.
Update!
The VOD is surprisingly still alive.
Um, and you're asking and uh... So um, I went to bed, so I didn't edit the VOD right away.
So I was like, if I wake up, two things is gonna... are gonna... is gonna happen.
Either the stream gets demonetized or my channel's gone.
So I was like, all right, let's go gambling.
Because, you know, I could have just stayed up and waited until the video process and then edit... edit the stuff out, like, you know, on the day, but I was tired.
So I was like, I like my odds.
If my channel disappears, you know what?
It's... it was the right time to retire at that... at that point.
That... that's my peak.
You know how you're like, retire at your peak?
I was like, you know what?
If anything, if that's gonna be my peak, I'm fine with that.
I'm... I'm like, fine.
So... so... so I was like, all right.
Now, what I didn't realize was there was a hidden third secret option.
And that was basically... nothing happened.
What do you mean by nothing happened, Doki?
The VOD was not demonetized!
And it did not get age-restricted.
Not only did it not get demonetized, it didn't even get age-restricted.
So I was like, oh, okay, thank God.
Anyway, um...
I'm not gonna push my luck.
So I woke up, I edited the VOD.
So like, I blurred out, you know, I blurred out the parts that...
You know, might not be very friendly.
Might not be something that should be on an un-age-restricted VOD.
So I did blur it, but it takes a while to process.
So chat is still alive.
But...
Today... today will be the last day chat's gonna be alive.
So... so...
If you want to see live chat, if you want to see people's reaction with the live chat, today is literally the last day it's gonna be alive before the chat's gone forever.
I mean, the chat's technically on the screen.
But like, you know what I mean?
Like, the live chat on the side, because whenever you edit a VOD, whenever you edit the VOD, the chat disappears.
And today's the... today will be the last day you have it will have the live chat.
Because after that, it's like sayonara.
After that, it's just goodbye forever.
But yeah, that's some... some fun news.
I'm just... I'm equally as surprised as all of you guys that...
It survived, because...
Whoa.
Gordon, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
I made a bet yesterday that the VOD would get taken down, yet it still stands.
Undemonetized, no age restricting.
I am a man of my word.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, Fumbati, you're still mine!
Fucking, you should have shown your face.
That was a birthday present.
It's not your birthday anymore.
Anyway.
Oh, is the live chat gone for real?
Okay, then.
Sorry, guys.
If the live chat is now gone for... is now gone on the VOD, you were too late.
I warned you guys too late.
It's gone.
But at least the video...
The video is saved now.
The video has now been saved.
All right, all right.
Today...
So today...
Since yesterday, I showed you guys how good I am with the ladies.
And technically, you guys can...
Okay, but like...
Guys, it's not about the journey.
The journey.
It's about the end game.
And I did get the lady in the end.
So since yesterday, I showed you guys how good I am with the ladies.
Today, I'm gonna show you guys that I'm actually smarter than a child.
That I'm a fucking genius by showing you guys how much smarter I am than a fucking 10-year-old.
So I am here.
What do you mean redemption arc?
Yesterday, I got with a woman.
Not only...
Not only is she not just a girl.
She was a woman.
So I made it.
It's about the end game.
You cried when you saw her.
Anybody would!
They were D-cups.
I mean, you would too.
Jake, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Doki.
It's my birthday today.
Thank you for always making the day with better streams.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, Marcy, it's my birthday on Sunday.
So take my money.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
A double birthday song?
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Jake and Marcy.
Yeah!
Happy birthday, guys!
All right.
Awesome day!
Thank you for the gifted ship.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, today's the day.
Today's the day you will stop laughing at me for being dumb.
Because now you'll know that I'm smarter than a goddamn 10-year-old.
Today's that day.
All right, let's...
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Okay, give me a sec.
What the fuck was the stream deck shit that just popped out on my fucking screen?
I was like, it's time to update your stream deck.
And I'm like, what?
I don't even have stream deck plugged in.
All right, let's see.
I've never played...
I've actually never watched this show before.
So like, this is like also my...
There's a...
Oh my god, I forgot the game.
I had to resize the game because...
I had to resize this because of HuniePop.
There's a lot of firsts for this week.
Never played or watched HuniePop gameplay.
Never watched are you smarter than a fifth grader.
I just know it's like...
All right, US-based...
You know what?
I went to a United States international school.
It's almost the same thing.
Can't be that bad.
All right, what's classmate?
Permanent record?
School desk?
What's this?
Oh, standard gamer.
Oh, with the mom, dad, fussy baby.
Okay.
All right, let's see.
Um, I want to change...
Oh, I can change my...
I can add stuff to my desk.
Oh, that's so cool.
I get to be like full customization.
All right, wow.
Wow-wee.
And then I'm gonna have...
Let's see.
We should have...
Okay, yeah.
I think we should have that.
And then we should also add this so people would know that I'm gonna become a lawyer when I grow up.
All right, here we go.
And then icon.
We're going for an icon.
Guys, this is very important.
Before we go in, we gotta have like...
We gotta have like the drip, you know?
We gotta have like...
People know that how smart I am by just looking at my desk.
Like the AI.
I need the NPCs to register in the algorithm that I am serious.
All right, let's get the telescope.
I mean the microscope.
Let's get the microscope, guys.
All right, aquatic aerial.
Okay, quantum gamer.
Oh, wait.
Nuclear gamer.
There we go.
Great start.
No!
All right, I remember what it looked like, guys.
Don't worry.
There we go.
Was it this?
Yeah, I wanted to be a lawyer.
I remember.
All right, here we go.
Everything's good.
Um, Potato.
Thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you.
Liam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, Doki.
The whole point of the game is that you play a loser who needs a fairy to use her magic powers in order to get them a day.
No, no, no!
I didn't use...
The only magic power I used from a fairy that doesn't exist, by the way.
It's all in my head, because I didn't take my meds.
Is her stalker, like, her stalker ray.
So, like, that was the only help I got.
Other than that, everything else was me, all natural, Riz, right there.
And I got a lady in the end.
Within three hours of meeting her, we went to bed.
And, like, it was a little scary.
But, like, we got to the end.
Just a little scary.
But, we made it.
We made it to the goal.
So, that's all that matters.
Oh, am I...
Is this me?
I thought I was an adult.
Oh, no, it's just...
Oh, it's the kids.
I'm fighting.
Okay.
Oh, my God, who is this fucking nerd?
Oh, no, he's not even an all-rounder.
He's just really good at math.
Like, he has a D in humanities?
How do you have a D plus in humanities?
It's like his...
Oh, like, it's almost like history.
Wait, I don't remember what you learn in humanities.
Not gonna lie.
I'm fighting children.
Yes, because they're fifth graders.
All right.
We're fine.
These...
I looked at their stats.
They're...
They're so bad.
All right, exam mode.
All right, they're a nuclear gamer.
I bring up the game a little bit.
Don't worry, I got you.
All right.
I brought it up.
Hey, Teddy.
Wait, your name is Theodore?
Two hosts?
They're sixth grade?!
Are you smarter than a sixth grader?
I thought fifth grade was the limit!
Where the fuck did sixth grade come...
That's different.
That's middle school.
That's a whole new territory.
Chat is not cheating, by the way.
Chat, six is one more than five.
Exactly!
No cheats, no classmate.
Let's see if you can prove that you really are smarter than a fifth grader.
That's actually so fucked up!
Oh, turn it up even more.
Don't worry, I got you.
Wait, maybe if there's...
I forgot to look at the most important part like this.
Maybe I'm gonna turn down the music and effects.
Yeah, the music and effects are so loud.
All right, that should be fine.
And it'll turn up the game a little bit more.
All right.
Okay, first grade.
That's like addition problems.
We'll get the math out of the way.
Who is it?
I don't remember who was good at math.
Is Hayley good at math?
Are you good at math?
It's literally first grade.
How can you fuck up math, Hayley?
That's not math!
She's not doing math!
Teddy!
You know what?
I'm gonna test you in math.
I know it's not in your category, but like it's the first grade.
We're gonna get the math part out of the way.
Hayley, we're gonna get the math part out of the way now.
So like...
So like, I know like math is not your strongest, but it's first grade.
There's no way you could fuck up first grade math.
Like it's literally like additions and subtractions in first grade.
Maybe a little bit of multiplication and division, but like we need a math out now.
All right.
How bad can it be?
I...
What?
What the fuck is a whole number?
Two?
What?
What's a...
What's a whole number?
Is that a number when it's...
When it's full?
It's two, right?
I did not learn this at first.
What the fuck is a whole number?
Like it's a number that's full, right?
Okay, is that the opposite of prime numbers?
Is that it?
Is it the opposite of prime?
Fuck off, Hayley!
You don't...
Hayley, no, you...
Okay, no.
Hayley, you go in.
Hayley, you come in.
I need somebody to explain what whole numbers are.
All right.
Okay, cheat.
New question.
Ask the class.
What's copy?
Am I copying her homework?
All right, what's your homework, Hayley?
All right, Hayley, don't fuck this up.
It's first grade and you're a fifth grader.
If you can't even figure out what a whole number is, then...
Then you're as fucked as me.
But it's even worse for you because it's been like a lot of years since first grade.
I wanted to pick two.
Hayley.
Hayley, I...
Hayley!
I was gonna pick two.
But I didn't believe in myself.
That's not even my fault!
I was gonna pick two because I was like...
A whole number has to be like...
A number that's a full number, right?
Because it's whole...
I failed?
I...
This is the first grade...
This is Hayley's fault.
Oh my gosh.
Fuck Hayley.
Oh my god.
I was not confident in myself because you guys were all judging me.
You were all judging me.
I wasn't confident.
I didn't even let you insta-fail.
That's...
That's a practice round, guys.
Guys, this was a practice round chat.
It doesn't mean anything.
It's a practice round.
Now, it's the real game.
It's the real fucking game.
Alright.
I'm gonna...
Spelling can't be that bad.
It's literally...
You're just spelling a word.
You're spelling a word.
I'm getting the harder subjects out of the way.
How many times does the letter A appear in the name of the following state?
Alabama.
A-L-A-B-A-M-A...
Four.
I counted on my fingers.
It's three.
Final answer, Teddy.
Wait.
A-L-A-B-A-M-A...
It's four.
Why are you saying...
Guys, you're fucking me up.
It's four.
Like, A...
Okay.
A-L-A-B-A-M-A...
It's four.
Three is four.
So, the answer is...
Four.
Thank God.
You guys are fucking me up.
I see three.
I thought you meant, like, there's three A's.
And I was like, there's no way there's three A's in Alabama.
But you didn't even help.
Shit, Ellie.
I used my fingers.
Oh my God.
I don't care.
When would I get to show my channel?
Subscribe to me at DokiBrit at YouTube.
Lord, gross.
I still have Ellie?
Dumb is cute.
My oshi is just spiriting to just show us how cute she is.
Thank you for the akasu.
You know what?
Social studies, Ellie.
Come in here.
I know you're smart.
You got glasses on, just like me.
The fuck?
Winter?
It's winter.
Yeah.
It's December, January.
That has to be...
What kind of...
What kind of question is this?
It has to be winter.
Like, how could you fuck this up?
Why would it be summer?
How could January, December be...
Oh my God, thank God.
Ellie, stop cheering.
If I...
I wish I could see what his answer was.
I...
A first grade question?
We had one...
It asked me what a whole number is.
What the fuck is a whole number?
Yeah, second grade!
Let's go!
We upgraded!
Guys, we got promoted.
We skipped a grade.
We skipped the grade chat.
It's over for him.
Oh...
All right, who's my new...
Who's my new helper?
Joaquim.
All right, Joaquim.
Your movie sucked, but like, let's go.
That's the point, Doki.
You're not supposed to mess these up.
They give us super chat...
Geometry and what?
Guys, guys!
Guys!
Wait...
Geometry and what?
Oh, math.
Okay.
You know what?
I don't need your help, Joaquim.
I can read.
My email is jokeycanread.
I would never lie about that.
The fuck is the wind in the willow?
What?
The wind in the willows?
The fuck is a black mamba?
Is that a real animal?
That sounds like...
I don't know.
The fuck is a black mamba?
Okay, when I start reading, it'd be like the SATs.
This is not the SATs.
This is literally like...
I should have read this book.
Like, I...
Why would I have read this book?
Like...
That's not reading material!
Oh my god.
I would say the mold.
I feel like a lot...
I feel like...
If I was in second grade, I wouldn't be like...
There was a black mamba.
I'd be like...
There's a mold right there.
It has to be a mold.
There's no way.
That's like the easiest animal for second graders.
I fuck!
Oh, thank god.
I was like...
Second graders are too stupid to know what the fuck a black mamba is.
I don't even know what it is.
There's no way.
I know a lot of animals, but I don't know what the fuck a black mamba is.
Why are we learning about Joaquin?
He didn't do jack shit.
Fucking nerd.
A whole number is a basic counting number.
Any decimals, fractions, or negatives.
Yeah, and thank you for the...
Math!
Okay.
Math.
Joaquin, this is it.
This is your zone.
This is it.
Joaquin.
This is where you gotta...
Wait, what?
Who would learn square roots in second grade?
I was learning multiplications.
End of...
Okay.
All right, Joaquin.
This is it.
This is your time to shine, Joaquin.
This is...
I learned square roots not in second grade.
I'm doing multiplications and divisions.
Okay, yeah.
All right, Joaquin.
This is your best division.
I don't...
What is the square root?
Wait, what does square root even mean?
I forgot what square root even means.
Oh.
Wait, I...
Guys, it's been years.
What is the square root again?
It's been a long time.
It's been a while.
Guys, it's not because I'm stupid.
It's because I had no reason to use math.
And like, when will I ever use square root ever in my life?
Like, who would just go up to you and be like, what's the square root of 64?
Like, how is that a life or death situation in any way?
Like, what...
In what way can I utilize the square root in real life?
And why...
It's because Joaquin is a math god.
I'm gonna use his strengths.
Oh my god, I made it.
I fucking made it, guys.
I skipped another grade.
It only took me five minutes to complete second grade.
Goodbye, Joaquin.
Goodbye.
Who's my next helper?
Architecture and engineers?
Engineers in my chat!
Does anyone ever...
Does your...
Oh, he's spelling and reading.
Okay.
God, I fucking hate you, Hayley.
You fucked me up last time.
All right, engineers in my chat.
Does your employer ever go up to you and was like, Hey there, Mr. Engineer.
What's the square root of 64?
In what context would they go up to you and to tell...
Ask you about the square root?
All right, you know what?
We can do vocabulary.
Okay.
No, they're maps.
That's false.
Cartographers are maps.
What the f- Okay, false.
I know what cartography is.
It's for maps.
False.
Yes!
Well, the actual answer is...
False.
Oh, thank God.
I go second-guessing myself.
I was like...
Am I gaslighting myself about that?
Because I can't read maps.
So how the fuck did I know what cartographer was?
I don't even know how I found out what...
Minecraft.
Thank you, Minecraft.
When teachers tell you gaming will not help you in any way, they're liars.
Because I learned what cartography was from Minecraft.
What was it?
Vocabulary and spelling?
Right?
Okay, inter-reading.
Okay, spelling.
All right.
All right, Hayley.
This is your favorite subject, Hayley!
It's not math this time!
You can't mess this up, Hayley!
It's not math!
Astronaut?
E-X-T-R-A-T-E-R-R...
E-S...
Extra...
Terresti...
True...
Wait...
E...
E-X-T-R-A-T-E-R-R-R-E-S-T-O...
Three!
It's three!
There's three R's!
Wait, guys, don't fuck me up here.
E-X-T-R...
I'm like, writing...
I'm like, writing it on my mousepad.
T-E-R-R-S-E-S-T...
Terresti...
Oh, three!
Okay, it's three.
It's three!
Stop saying...
Don't, guys!
No, it's not.
I can't...
Don't say it's not four.
There's no way.
Terresti...
Extra-terrestial...
Wait, what?
Where did the extra R come from?
Someone spelled it extra...
Terrestrial?
No!
I thought it's extra-terrestial.
It's terrestrial.
I thought...
He should have used it in the sentence.
If he used it in the sentence, I would have known.
Like...
All I'm saying, chat...
Is that...
If he used it in a sentence...
It would have...
I would have...
It would have been fine.
He didn't use it in a sentence, so it messed me up.
If this was your...
If this was a...
No!
Daddy, no!
Put me back in, Daddy!
I swear!
I figured it out!
Minecraft sure did teach you how to spell.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, guys, guys...
I pronounced it wrong and like...
There wasn't any subtitles.
And like...
He didn't use it in a sentence, guys.
He didn't use it in the sentence, so it messed me up.
We're never getting to fifth grade level at this...
No, guys!
It was...
This is a practice round.
Now...
Now, it's the real deal.
Now, we're actually playing the game.
This was like an audition, guys.
Also, Quantum, thank you for the five gifted ships.
Thank you, thank...
Guys, this was just like an audition to be Are You Smarter Than a Fifth Grader.
I passed, so...
Because I passed, we're actually on the show now.
World geography and animals?
Does this look like there's world geography?
Okay, social studies, dude.
It can't be that bad.
Social studies was really easy.
I'm not American?
I don't even have...
I don't even...
Guys, I don't even have a...
I'm fucking Canadian!
You know what we have on our nickel?
A beaver.
Like, like...
I don't know!
I have a beaver on my nickel?
I don't fucking know!
Is it true?
Okay, look.
I can use...
I should be allowed to use assistance.
Because I just know what a Canadian nickel looks like.
Like...
We're not keeping time, so take your time.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, thank God.
Is it true or false?
Guys...
Oh my God.
Okay, it's the beaver named Thomas Jefferson.
I don't know!
You know what?
We're gonna ask the class.
All right, class.
Any Americans in my class right now?
What do they think?
Are there any Americans in my class?
Do you have your coins with you?
Oh, thank God.
It's true, okay.
All right, okay.
The whole class thinks it's true, guys.
The whole class.
The real question is Thomas Jefferson the beaver.
Thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
My Americans think it's true.
My American classmates think it's true.
Oh, thank God.
I was gonna be like, none of my classmates are American if they don't know this.
We did not need to know.
I don't have...
What do you want me to do?
Google the answer.
Be like, Alexa, what is the...
I don't even have a fucking...
Whatever the Alexa shit is.
All right.
All right, let's do vocabulary.
How bad can that be?
It's like first grade.
It's a first grade vocab question.
Oh, plane.
Okay, first graders don't know jack shit about aviation.
Like, it's one.
Guys, don't like gaslight me.
Like, I know it's one.
Because aviation is like avian.
And avian is a bird.
So like, and I'm jokey bird.
So like, because I know what birds are, I know it has to be a plane.
I'm saying eight-year-olds should not...
Eight is like first grade, right?
Or seven.
They should not know what the fuck aviators are.
Like, how?
How would they know what an aviator is?
That's not first grade level.
I didn't know what aviators are.
To be fair, I refuse to read in first grade.
That might be the worst possible logic.
This ain't about you, Amelia Earhart.
Okay, but like, she's American.
And like, I was in Canada in first grade.
And we did not give a fuck about Amelia Earhart.
I learned about Amelia Earhart from Night at the Museum.
Because nobody in Canada cared about who Amelia Earhart was.
Oh shit, she's fluent in languages.
I already forgot.
Okay, foreign languages and social studies.
Oh, thank God!
Thank God, Ava.
We have social studies right now.
That sounds Hawaiian.
That has to be Hawaiian, right?
Like, I mean...
That's a Hawaiian word.
Like...
That's literally a...
I don't think it's Mississippi.
Or South Dakota.
Wherever the fuck South Dakota is.
Is there a North Dakota?
Wait, is there?
Wait, there is.
Is there a West Dakota?
Bro, what the fuck?
How many Dakotas are...
I don't even know how many Dakotas there are in fucking America.
But I know it's Hawaii.
I was like, it's South Dakota.
Now you're gonna tell me there's a North Dakota.
And I'm like, wait, there is a North Dakota.
I remember.
I remember there's a North Dakota.
Thank God, Ava.
Yeah, give us a little fun fact.
Oh, wait, really?
That's cool.
That's so cool, Ava.
Also, give me a sec.
I need to...
I need to adjust my volume real quick, guys.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
Alright, we're back in it.
Alright, Ava.
Alright, social studies.
Nobody's gonna save us in either of these.
So...
So we're gonna do social studies.
Alright.
Isn't that the cult?
That's the cult, right?
That's the Kool-Aid.
Why is the Kool-Aid thing in my fucking...
Why is it...
Oh my God.
I don't even know where each of the state is.
Oh, that's Jonestown.
Wait, what the fuck is...
There's several...
There's several J-towns?
Where am I?
Okay, that's...
That's Hawaii.
That's Alaska.
Because I know...
I know that's supposed to be Canada.
Yeah, okay.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
I don't even know what state I'm in right now.
Is this Florida?
That's Florida, because it's the dick, right?
I'm like, where am I?
Where have you been?
Okay, what...
This is West, and so East is here.
All right, I don't know where...
I don't even know where I am right now.
Like, what is this state?
I'm cheating.
There's no way.
I can't even recognize any of the states.
Oh my God, like...
I don't know if Ava can even answer this.
Her fucking best subjects are...
Her best subjects are like...
Okay, I'm asking you, all right.
Ava, what do you think, Ava?
That's it?
Ava, answer.
Tell me the answer.
All right, Ava.
It's all on you.
I didn't get past the second grade.
It's all on you, Ava.
If it's so fucking easy.
Oh,
please, Ava.
Please, you must know geography better than me.
What is it?
What the fuck even is that?
They don't even tell me what state this is?
It's all blocks to me.
Is that Virginia?
Oh shit, okay, it's Virginia.
What even is a Jamestown?
Is Jamestown supposed to be famous?
Like...
Oh my God, she's so locked in.
She knows her country.
If only Jamestown was in Minecraft, then I would know.
All right.
It's a town owned by James.
Is this where all the James came from?
Any fellow James, can you vouch that you came from Jamestown?
The birthplace of all James.
Oh my God, I made it.
I made it to the third grade chat.
Oh my God, goodbye, Ava.
Thanks for coming in clutch.
Every James came from Virginia.
If you want to name your child James, you have to give birth in Virginia.
All right, Joaquim, you got this, Joaquim.
All right, Joaquim, this is it.
I think we only have math or geometry left.
All right, wait, I can't even ask a classmate because I already asked him.
Okay.
You know what?
Let's go with...
Let's go with life sciences.
I have...
I don't have cheats anymore, so we're gonna go with life sciences.
Because, like, he can't help me anyway.
He can't help me.
I already used my ask a classmate.
All right.
Let's go.
Like, what?
What's...
How difficult is life science anyway?
Mercury poisoning may occur if you eat too much of certain types of fish.
What?
Why would you even...
Nuclear...
No?
Pick an answer for us.
What fish?
What kind of fish...
What do you mean...
What kind of fish does that?
Wait.
Could I be getting mercury poisoning?
Like...
Have I been unintentionally giving myself mercury poisoning?
That's a thing?
Wait, true?
Oh my God.
There's no way.
What?
What fish?
Teddy, what fish?
Teddy, no, you can't just say true.
What fish, Teddy?
What...
Fish?
What fish?
How do I avoid not getting mercury poisoning?
What fish, Teddy?
Salmon?
I eat so much salmon.
Am I getting...
Have I been giving myself mercury poisoning this entire time?
I live in Canada, chat!
That is like the one fish we always eat.
That's...
It's like our...
I have smoked salmon in my fucking fridge.
What are you...
I literally have smoked salmon right now in my goddamn fridge.
What do you...
What do you mean I get mercury?
Why did it take me this long to find that out from a fucking video game?
About fifth graders.
It's a national fish of Canada.
Okay, why did we give ourselves merc...
All right, you know what?
I feel a little adventurous.
I might die soon because I have mercury poisoning, apparently.
I've been slowly giving myself mercury poisoning.
Wait, is this 13 times 4?
Hey, that's 13 times 4.
I'm pretty sure it's not.
Guys, what's 13 times 70...
Oh, it's 13 times 4.
Okay, 13 times 4...
4, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
That's 2, 4...
52!
Wait, how is my answer different?
How's my answer...
Wait, no, I fucked up.
That's a dish...
Guys, I...
How is my...
How...
Wait, 5?
Why is it 5?
It gave birth to 4.
13 times...
Where did the 13 and 5 come from?
Oh my god, I'm...
Oh no...
Where did the 13 come from?
Oh wait, 13 is what it says.
Wait, where did the 5 come from?
Wait...
Oh, 52?
Plus...
13...
5...
65!
It's 65, guys.
Guys, it's 65.
Guys, I figured it out.
It's 65.
This has to be it.
There's no way.
Guys, I...
Guys, I'm learning how to read live right now with you guys.
But it's 65.
I...
Plus the 13.
Plus...
Please tell me it's 65.
Oh, thank god.
No doubt you're out, Wocky.
Without your fucking help, Wocky.
Oh my god, we're...
It's okay.
We're doing it.
We're learning.
We're figuring it out as we go along.
Oh my god, we're in fourth grade.
We're halfway.
Guys, we're one grade away from fifth grade.
Our personal best chat.
I can't believe I asked the class in first grade because I didn't have a nickel.
I already used my...
Asked the class because of it.
Just because I didn't have a...
That's just because I'm not American.
It wasn't fair.
It's not fair.
All right, spelling.
It can't be...
Spelling.
We can do this.
We'll redeem ourselves.
We'll redeem ourselves here, chat.
This is it.
This is where we're gonna redeem everything, guys.
I believe.
Johnny, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
So, textbooks are expensive, but I feel like I might end up buying one.
So there's something to help out.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
The fourth letter of the following word.
Voice.
What?
What did she say?
S.
C.
Voice?
What did she say?
If you're a gamer, choose the right answer.
Wait, repeat your...
Wait.
Repeat question.
What is the fourth letter of the following word?
Voice.
Is it voice?
I.
V-O-I-C.
Oh, it's C.
It's C.
It's now locked in.
How is this fourth grade?
The answer is...
C.
How is this fourth grade?
I got extraterrestrial at second grade.
How did I get extraterrestrial at second grade?
And then voice at fourth?
Oh my god.
Extraterrestrial.
Sorry, extraterrestrial.
Okay, social studies.
Because like, they're not helping me out anyway.
Social studies time.
Like, I'm literally...
I have to go in blind now.
The former site of the Ottoman Empire is now known as...
Turkey!
Wait, am I wrong?
Nuclear gamer, pick up your answer.
If I get that wrong?
It is.
Yeah, it's Turkey.
But where is Turkey?
Wait, where the fuck is...
Wait.
Okay, I got the...
I got the name right.
But where is Turkey?
Guys.
Guys, I got...
No, I got the answer right.
But where the fuck is Turkey?
Wait, no.
Wait, where's Turkey though?
I don't know.
Okay.
Where could Turkey be?
Wait, where's Greece?
Guys, you can't be like, it's next to Greece.
I don't even know where Greece is.
Wait, where the fuck is Turkey?
Guys, I...
Guys, okay.
This is obviously Russia.
This has to be Russia right here.
Isn't this...
This not Turkey?
I'll say the question once more.
Please.
Where is it?
Where could it be?
Okay.
I don't know.
But...
To the left?
I was right.
Is this...
This is Turkey?
Turkey's that big?
Is that...
I swear to God, if this is not Turkey, I swear...
I swear to fucking God.
Oh yeah, because I...
No, I...
I need to load like, land borders now.
Okay.
I need to know the fucking land borders of countries now.
Like, the fuck is this?
No fourth graders should know this.
Mr. San, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Buns to add a T between can and read.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
It's time to check out the points again.
Oh my God, we made it so far.
Guys, we made it so far.
Guys, we can't fuck this up, chat.
Oh my God.
Wait, are we...
Are we in the fifth grade now?
Are we gonna be in the fifth grade?
Did we...
We made it!
We made it to the fifth grade!
Oh my God, chat, we did it!
We're almost gonna head to middle school.
Goodbye, you were no fucking help, Ellie.
Our personal best.
Oh my God, our personal best, guys.
We peaked.
Well, it doesn't matter.
This is all cosmetic.
It's like...
It's like, have a child by your side that's just there.
Like, as your emotional support.
I was gonna say animal, but I was like, I shouldn't say that about kids.
My emotional support child.
You know what?
I feel like I've been crushing it at life sciences.
Reading is just bullshit.
Reading was literally like, hey, read...
Do you know what's in this?
What is...
I'm not...
Guys, guys, I don't think...
Guys, we're not making it out of the fifth grade and we're doing measurements.
I don't know any of my measurements, guys.
I don't know.
I don't know, guys.
I don't...
I don't think I could do measurements, guys.
I...
I want to make it past fifth grade, chat.
Like...
I guess...
And the worst part is that US measurements are different from the rest of the world.
It's...
It's different from the rest of the world.
I haven't failed life sciences yet.
All right.
As the father of genetics, what Austrian...
Wait...
Mende?
Right?
Gregor Mendel.
Yeah.
Carl Linnaeus.
Mende.
George Washington Carver.
The fuck is the president to?
George Washington Carver?
Like, what did the president fucking do?
I knew it.
I...
Oh my god.
Guys, the reason why I knew about the pea plants is the box thing.
The box grid.
And we did that so much.
And it's Gregor Mendel.
I fucking...
I remember.
Wait, Carver isn't a president?
Who the fuck is George Washington Carver?
That's a different...
Wait...
Who's George Washington Carver?
Who is he?
Thank you for joining us.
You know who Mendel is, but you don't know what whole number is.
I was...
I was acting.
Guys...
Guys, I was acting.
All right.
I told you.
Life sciences is where we at.
Okay.
I know vocabulary.
Like...
What...
What kind of vocabulary question would be a bad vocabulary question that's gonna ruin this run?
Like...
What was...
We're not doing...
Guys, reading is like...
Here's a book.
Who wants to...
You don't...
Fuck it.
All right.
Let's...
Let's see how bullshit this question is.
All right.
We have...
We have a...
We can like ask a different question.
If we fuck this up.
Oh!
Oh.
Guys, I never watched...
I never read The Giver, but I knew this...
Joe?
Is it Nick?
It sounds like...
Nick Jonas.
Is it the Jonas Brothers?
Is it...
I...
You know what?
In memory of the Jonas Brothers...
Because we had Nick Jonas in the Jonas Brothers.
I...
It was...
The Giver was popular around the time the Jonas Brothers were really popular for like...
Elementary and middle school students.
So like...
By the power...
Of the three boys...
I would pick...
Jonas.
Wait, Joe Jonas too!
Wait, isn't Joe also a Jonas Brother?
Okay, it has to be Jonas.
It has to be Jonas.
Oh, thank Jonas Brothers!
Oh, thank God!
Oh my God!
Oh, the Jonas Brothers came in clutch!
It brought us classic like...
The turns have tabled.
One last question!
We can't fumble this!
There's no way we can fuck this up.
Guys, there's no way.
There's no way.
Praise to be a Jonas Brother, right?
There's no way we could fuck this up, chat.
Like, how?
You know what?
I'm so confident that we made it to middle school!
Let's do it.
Let's fucking do it.
I'm so confident.
This is like my character arc.
We led up to like the hardest subject ever in America in freedom units.
Hoppus.
Happus.
Nuclear gamer.
Do you have the answer?
What?
Hippocampus?
Wait, how is this measurement?
Hippus.
Hippus, hoppus, happus.
What the fuck?
Wait.
One hippus, please.
I know, I know.
I like one.
One hoppus of timber, my good sir.
What the fuck?
What the fuck are these units?
Um, all right.
I don't...
Ah, hippus.
You got the answer.
Well, the right answer is...
Hoppus.
Good try, but that's not the right answer.
Unfortunately, you are not smarter than a fifth grader.
But we'd love to have you again very soon.
But I made it to sixth grade!
Let's see what that did to your final scores.
Congratulations, what a great score!
I made it to...
I...
Who can answer that?
Who the fuck?
That didn't be on my permanent record?
I thought...
I thought schools don't look at your permanent record until high school.
I just made it to middle school.
What do you...
What do you mean?
What do you mean I...
I put something on my permanent record.
Oh, don't you...
Don't...
No, I'm not gonna get into my top university choice chat.
She hippus on my hoppus till I have this.
Absolute imperial units.
America really won't teach any measurement, but...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ajoa.
For all I just wanna be.
Oh, please.
Get me out of school.
Oh, my God.
We were so close.
We were so fucking close.
I should have used ask a classmate in first grade.
But to be fair, I didn't think I'd make it that far.
I didn't think I'd make it this far.
There's something more fake than freedom units.
Blast.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, I repeated elementary school like four times.
All right.
All right, let's do reading.
Can't be that bad.
It's first grade.
True or false?
In The Lion, The Witch, and The Wardrobe...
Mr. Tumnus is a faun that lives in...
Is that what they're called?
That the...
The half...
No, he's a goat.
He's not a faun.
He's a goat.
Played by James McAvoy.
God, he was so hot in that.
He was so...
He was...
Is that what they're called?
A faun?
But he was like a half goat thing.
What?
James McAvoy was...
Was Mr. Tumnus!
Okay.
True.
Oh, thank God.
Thank you, James McAvoy.
So, Halima.
Thanks for joining us here.
Can you tell us a fun fact you learned recently?
Yeah, Helena.
Never feed honey to a baby less than a year old.
The bacteria can cause infant botulism.
Oh my God, Halima just unlocked a new fear.
Like...
Oh my God.
Does that mean they die?
Wait, Halima, what the fuck?
Like, how is that a fun fact, Halima?
Like...
How is that...
That wasn't fun at all.
How is that fun?
This...
The fuck?
No.
No, it is a fruit.
That's false.
There's no way.
That has to be false.
There's no fucking way.
Alright, it has to be false.
There's no way.
When you want a fruit juice, mango is in it.
Like, mango's in...
Mango's like...
In a fruit juice.
Okay, I...
I thought I was getting gasolated my entire life.
I'm like...
I'm second doubting myself now.
Like...
I'm actually...
I'm second doubting myself in reality.
Like, I don't know.
I was like, oh my god.
Have I been living a lie?
Are mangoes actually a vegetable this entire time?
Like...
Was I...
Was I fucking with myself when I thought it was a fruit?
Okay, I'm not okay.
I had hippest, hoppest, and huppest.
Like...
I'm not okay.
What the fuck is a hoppest?
Like, how much is a hoppest?
Anyway, how many centimeters is in a hoppest?
Why did they ditch hoppest as a...
We all know why they ditched hoppest as a measuring unit.
Because why the fuck would you call...
Why would you call...
I am five hoppests tall.
Like, who says that?
Who...
Okay.
That's...
All right, world geography.
I don't think we've ever had world geography or animal science.
All right, vocabulary.
No, spelling.
It's second grade.
It can't be that bad.
I'll cast a spell on you.
Wait.
September,
October, November, the 9th?
January, February, March, April, May, June, July, August, September, September, October, November, ABCDEFGHIJKLMNOP...
Okay.
Sorry.
I need to make sure.
I knew S was after N.
But then, now that I'm put in this prescient situation, I'm like, is it though?
Like, is it really after N?
I'm like, I'm second-guessing everything, chat.
Like, I'm like, is it actually after N now?
Like, I don't know.
I don't know anymore.
Like, it has to be the ninth month.
It has to be.
Has to be.
Yes, we did it.
September.
Let's go, September.
Let's go.
The hop is actually broken.
The hop is an extraterrestrial.
Let's check the next question.
I think the most fun fact was from the girl that said...
Don't give children...
Don't give babies honey, or they'll die.
I'm like, thank you for the fun fact?
All right.
You know what?
Let's do measurement.
It's second grade.
It can't be as bad as sixth grade now.
There's no way it's worse than sixth grade.
It was so fun.
Kilo is more than grams, right?
Oh.
What's just...
What's the...
Oh.
What's a kilogram?
That's what...
Wait, what's...
What's kg?
Don't do this to us.
It's just you and us.
Take as long as you need.
No, Teddy, don't say that.
I have...
I have 14 people judging me right now.
It's not just us, Teddy.
It's...
No, it's so much worse.
It's so much worse.
It's not just us.
No pressure.
No.
Okay.
Oh, shut the fuck up, guys.
All right, let's...
Let's get a new question in.
Let's get...
I've...
I died.
Okay.
Wait, the same type?
What?
What's three quarters?
How is this worse?
How is this...
How is this harder?
It's just harder.
How much is three quarters of a meter?
How many millimeters is a meter?
It's like a hundred, right?
No, it's not a hundred.
It's like a thousand, right?
It's like a thousand millimeters.
It's a thousand millimeters?
Please, Teddy.
You can't do this to me.
Is it a thousand millimeters in a meter?
Or is it...
Like...
A thousand, right?
So it'd be three thousand and...
How much is three quarters?
That's three fourths.
So it's almost...
It's like three thousand seven fifty, right?
Because three quarters is like three fourths.
And like...
Quarters is like 25.50.75 a dollar.
Because we have the 25 cents in Canada.
So if there's a thousand...
It can't be a hundred millimeters.
It's like mili.
So if there's...
If it's three fourths and we do three fourths with quarters...
Because four quarters equals one dollar.
Then three quarters equals 75 cents.
There should be 750.
So I'm locking it in.
I'm locking it in.
I don't know where my logic is.
It's not beavers.
It's a fucking moose, you idiot.
Fucking Americans don't even know the quarter has a moose on it.
The quarter is...
Wait, I did it!
Oh my god!
I did it.
Guys, I don't know what the killer crab is.
Guys, I need you guys to know...
For 10 years of my life, I was in an American international school.
And in the first 10 years, I was in a Canadian school till middle school.
And then middle school to end of high school was an American international school.
So like, I don't know what a kilogram is.
I don't know.
My measurements are so fucked up.
Okay, chemistry and measurement.
Where were you when I needed you, Eli?
Where the fuck were you?
VTubing rotted her brain.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sounds like cope.
Okay.
All right.
What was this thing?
You know what?
Vocabulary has never failed...
Has never failed me.
Yes?
It's your chance to answer.
It's like superlatives is like most likely to succeed and stuff like that.
Like it's like most of something because it's super.
So it's true because like that's what you do when you graduate in high school.
It's like most likely to become an actor.
Most likely to succeed.
It's like, yeah, the most of something.
So it has to be coldest because you can be like most cold area.
Most cold.
No, I don't fucking need to eat.
Like you're not good at both.
You're a science nerd.
Okay.
It has to be true.
Because you can't be like the more cold person.
Most likely to be cold.
Oh, thank God.
Oh my God.
Thank fucking God.
Here we go.
Yeah, well give us a fun fact, Eli.
If only you could tell me what fish produces mercury.
Like...
I still don't...
I learned today that fish...
Fucking eating more of a certain type of fish gives you mercury poisoning.
Like, it took me so long to learn that.
And salmon is one of the fishes.
Like, what?
How is salmon...
I have smoked salmon in my fridge.
Well, I have smoked salmon in my fridge right now.
Oh, no.
I think I'm gonna die.
What was it?
Measurements.
Um...
No, I'm not gonna use Eli.
I'm not...
I need to get out of here.
I...
I'll use help at fifth grade.
Exaggeration.
Alliteration.
Hyperbole.
Oh, hyperbole!
Palindrome.
Hyperbole!
I don't know what the fuck a palindrome is, but like, I know it's not alliteration.
So it has to be a hyperbole.
The fuck is a palindrome?
Well, the actual answer is...
Hyperbole.
Yeah!
I can't believe vocabulary is my best subject.
I can't believe...
Vocabulary should not be my best subject and yet... No, it is!
Guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but when I did the PSAT, I had the highest... I had the highest reading...
Reading and voc... What was it?
It wasn't a PSAT.
It was like reading and vocab or whatever.
It was two subjects.
It was like reading and uh...
What was the other one in the SAT?
So, let's greet your new classmate.
Comprehension.
Wait, is it reading comprehension?
Verbal.
Yeah.
Uh, reading and writing.
I had the highest PSAT score in my... in my grade.
So in my grade for... not grade.
In my school for reading and writing.
I don't know what happened.
I don't... How did I know?
Because the um... the... the life counselor...
Um, the life counselor took me and this other girl who had the highest math score in the PSAT in the grade.
And then like... and they took me and this other girl and was like congratulating us and was like congratulations.
You two... you two had like the highest score for your categories.
I don't know what happened after.
I don't know what happened to me after though.
Like...
I don't know what happened to me.
Like and then that's where I peaked guys.
That's... that's exactly where I peaked in life.
Okay, reading.
What happened?
Honestly, I can blame the mercury.
Oh my god.
Wait, I know this.
Wait, I don't know this.
Is it Nathaniel?
Mark Twain!
Mark Twain and the Adventures of Tom Sawyer.
I know this from The Simpsons.
It's Mark Twain.
It's Twain because like The Simpsons did a parody of it and then they talked about Mark Twain.
Thank you TV!
TV!
Never... when your teachers tell you that TV's gonna rot your brain, tell them a VTuber got past fourth grade.
Because of The Simpsons.
Fucking nerd.
See, that's a fun fact.
Wait, that's not even a fact.
That's just a hobby.
All right, social sex.
We are not doing these.
We're getting social sex this week.
That's not even a fact.
That's just a hobby.
Hayley.
How's this social sciences?
That's just history.
Oh my god!
Okay.
It's time to ask the class.
All right, class.
Where the fuck is that located?
Oh my god.
I don't know any... I only recognize Texas and Florida and Alaska and Hawaii on this fucking map.
Where's that?
Where the fuck is that?
Is that New York?
Is that Pennsylvania?
Sorry, Pennsylvania?
Okay, okay, it's below New York.
If it's below New York, then that has to be...
It's all New York.
Is this... Is this Pennsylvania?
Is that... Is that Pennsylvania?
I can't tell.
All right, Penn State, let's go.
Don't worry.
Take as long as you need.
All right.
The actual answer is Gettysburg, Pennsylvania.
Oh, thank god.
Did I get it?
Oh, I couldn't tell.
Okay, we got it.
We got Pennsylvania.
Am I...
Unfortunately,
you were not smarter than a fifth grader, but we'd love to see you here later.
Let's take a last look at the final scores.
You did great, but there's always more to learn.
When did this become GeoGuessr?
When did this... I... Oh my god, I was in Pennsylva...
I was in Pennsylvania.
I was actually in Pennsylvania.
How was I supposed to know that was part of the system?
Like, I was playing fucking GeoGuessr.
Like, why am I playing GeoGuessr?
Like, I don't understand.
This is it.
I... Oh my god, this is it.
I... Oh, oh, oh, this is it.
This is it.
Where is it?
Where... where is it?
I know there's this... I know that setting is in here somewhere.
Okay, all right, I'm fine.
I'm... I'm... I...
I've had enough.
I've...
I can't... I can't think.
I keep giving me geography questions.
After the Gettysburg, I'm...
I'm fucking... I snapped the U.S.
out of existence.
I... I... I fucking got rid of the United States.
I'm fucking... It's gone.
The country's gone.
At least I knew... I knew, like... I knew it was Turkey.
That was actually bullshit.
All right.
Okay, we can do it.
Okay, there's... there's no way we can fuck it up now.
Kanna's taking back Alaska today.
We're gonna take back Alaska.
All right, Hayley, I don't need your help.
It's literally the first grade.
All right, spelling.
It's first grade spelling.
It's first grade.
C?
What's a consonant?
Wait, what's a consonant, chat?
Oh, it's not a vowel.
It's D.
Guys, guys, guys.
First... okay, guys, guys.
Like...
This is not cheating, guys.
Guys, it's not cheating.
I just... I just needed, like, clarification, guys.
It's not cheating.
I just need to know what the fuck a consonant is.
Guys, it's been many years since first grade.
How would you explain this?
When will you ever need consonants in real life?
You see, Hayley?
That's a fun fact, Hayley.
You gotta keep it light-hearted.
I thought that was so fun.
That's so fun learning that fact.
Vowels are, like, easier to know than...
Vowels are more...
Vowels are more an intuitive thing versus consonant.
Because you need vowels in many, many places.
But you don't need to learn what consonants are.
Because if you know what a vowel is, you don't need to know what consonants are.
You don't need to know what a consonant is if you know what a vowel is.
That's all I'm saying.
That's true.
Yeah.
That's a Venus flytrap.
Like, what else does it do?
It's true.
I watched the horror... What was it?
The, um, that musical where the Venus flytrap eats people?
Pet Shop of Horrors!
I know Pet Shop of Horrors.
There's actually a YouTube channel that does shorts with Venus flytraps and he talks about all the different... or Little Shop of Horrors.
Yeah.
And he talks about, like, how different species of flytraps kill insects because there's not more than one.
Guys, I mean, guys, this is it.
This is the... this is where... this just took longer than I expected.
This...
This took so... this is taking...
This is taking so long.
I thought I would be done by this game by now.
I might still not pass fifth grade.
We got fucked over by hippest hoppest happest, like...
Um...
Fucking hippest hoppest happest.
That's fucking horror.
Vocabulary.
How are you an IB student?
When will you ever learn hippest hoppest happest?
Which of the following would he most likely use to help navigate?
Microscope.
Periscope.
Telescope.
Nuclear gamer.
Do you have the answer?
Isn't it sonar?
The... I'm assuming microscope and telescope is not it.
I don't know what the fuck is a periscope, but I know it's not microscope or telescope.
So with the process of elimination, because this is for bacteria and this is for the fucking space.
Or being a creep.
So it has to be periscope, whatever the fuck that is.
We got your answer.
Yay!
I saw 100% true facts about the Venus flytrap.
Also, shout out to Z Frank.
Thank you for the super chat, Gary.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, I did it!
Process of elimination.
That's how I aced the PSAT.
If I didn't know what the question answer was, I know what the wrong answers were.
The dust from the Sahara often fertilizes the Amazon through wind.
What a good fact.
That's a good fact, too.
Yeah.
What a fun fact.
Did you know the Sahara Desert got flooded?
We've got...
Like, recently?
We are avoiding these two, like, there's no way.
Guys, we gotta finish this game eventually.
We know our fucking strong suits.
Which advance the ability to translate from several languages.
Rosetta?
Nuclear gamer picked the right answer.
The fuck?
I'm not even given a multiple choice?
I'm just chucked in?
I assume it's in Europe, right?
Like, maybe the Romans?
Where the fuck does the...
What is the Rosetta Stone?
Okay, wait.
Ask my classmate.
What grade am I in right now?
I'm in the second grade?
The fuck?
Why would you teach the second graders about the Rosetta Stone?
Oh my god, okay.
Okay.
I don't know.
All I can think about is, like, the Romans?
Like, I...
Because it's important?
Oh my god, don't be a fucking smartass right now, Kai.
Don't be...
Don't be a smartass right now, guys.
Oh my god, phone a chat!
Thank you, Vamp Cinder.
Now, where is Egypt?
Is it this?
Is this Egypt?
It's the one connecting, right?
Guys, it's not cheating.
I used phone a chat.
Guys.
Guys, it's not cheating, guys.
Phone a chat.
Phone a chat is a real thing, guys.
Is this Egypt?
This is Egypt?
Wait, Egypt is this big?
Oh my god.
I didn't realize Egypt was actually this big.
That's a huge...
That's huge.
I get to use one phone a chat.
That's my phone a chat, guys.
As a streamer, I have an additional option to phone a chat.
And it was a geography question.
So I should be allowed.
I have one.
It's like how all the other ones I had one.
This is my one phone a chat, guys.
This is my one phone a chat.
I get one.
Literally the one time I used it.
No, no, no.
This is one.
This is my one.
Guys, it's over.
Dr. S.
Shenanigans.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm in third grade.
Please, I just want to get to the...
Please, get me out of here.
Get me out of this school.
Please.
Okay, we're not gonna...
Which one was geography, guys?
Oh, shit.
When did we get vocabulary?
Wait, foreign languages.
Wait, I do foreign languages.
I do foreign languages.
That's not difficult.
Oh, Fiesta!
Let's go!
Let's have a Fiesta.
It's not Swahili.
That's not fucking Urdu, Swahili.
The fuck?
Yay!
Fiesta.
What the fuck is Urdu?
I know it's not Swahili.
I don't know where Urdu is.
It has to be Spanish.
My good old Espanol.
Let's go!
Shadow was right.
Let's go, Shadow!
My buddy, Shadow.
Oh, is Urdu...
Urdu, like, in...
Oh, it's in India?
Oh, it's India and Pakistan.
I have no idea.
Well, now I'm learning!
Hello, my fellow amigos!
Can you tell us a nice fact about yourself?
I'm currently reading Spanish epic poetry.
Oh my god, he could have actually helped me.
It's now time for the next question.
Nuclear Gamer.
Go and pick one of these subjects.
Oh my god, we keep doing foreign languages, but I've been acing life sciences, though.
Alright, do we do foreign language or...
Honestly, I've been acing foreign... I've been acing life sciences, but, like, foreign language is newer, so, like, we get other questions, too, so I'm gonna... Guys, we know our strong suit.
Alright.
What was the original language used in ancient Rome?
Latin.
Latin?
Italian.
Okay, it's not Italian.
Greek.
It's Latin.
Nuclear Gamer.
Or Greek.
Choose an answer.
It's Latin or Greek.
Is that Latin or Greek?
And I think it's Latin, because that's, like, my first...
Like, it's, like, my first instant...
It has to be Latin.
It has to be.
There's no way.
It's... I know it's not Italian.
But, like, it has to be... That has to be the original language, because it's, like...
Everything was always... It came from Latin.
It has to be Latin.
The answer is...
Latin.
Oh, thank God.
Because I know, like, the Romans stole, like, copied Greek for everything, so I was, like...
Oh, I went with my gut.
I was, like...
I was second guessing myself, because I was, like... Well, they, like, steal stuff from the Greek, so I was, like... Oh, my God.
Like...
So...
So, like, I was, like...
Oh, what if they stole Greek language, too?
Yeah.
They stole everything from the Greek.
Almost everything from the Greek.
So what if they also stole Greek from the Greeks?
I'm doubting myself.
Oh, look.
I've never had my self-esteem be crushed by this game.
Wait.
I've never felt, like, my ego and self-esteem get crushed this high.
Alright, life sciences, let's go!
Let's see what you can grow in this plants question.
True or false?
Giant sequoia trees grow until they're around 2,000 years old and then stop growing.
Choose your answer.
Oh, I...
Fuck, we still have those?
We still...
This is technically measurements.
That's cheating.
That's literally cheating.
This is technically...
This is technically measurements.
I assume false?
Because, like...
I don't know, like...
There's a tree out there that's...
That's, like, thousands of years old and it's giant.
It's fucking huge.
I assume that's the tree.
Like, how do they know?
Okay, the one thing that makes me think it's weird is that how do they know it's 2,000 years old?
That's when they stop growing.
Because they gotta cut the tree.
Shut the fuck up, Halima!
I'm trying to think!
I did not ask.
I've been stuck in, like, fourth grade.
I've been stuck in, like, fifth grade peak for an hour and 30 minutes now, Halima.
I need... Just shut up.
I'm trying to think.
Okay, anyway.
So, like, I'm just thinking, like, you gotta cut the tree to tell how old they are.
So, did they cut several trees?
And they're all, like, 2,000?
But, like, then they cut down a tree.
How would they know?
Like, why is it so...
Just shut up!
I'm trying to mull it along!
Okay, I'm gonna say false.
Because I'm thinking, like, there's no way, like, um...
I feel like 2,000 is just so specific.
Like, it just feels way too... I'm sorry.
I did not mean to yell at you, Halima.
I'm very stressed out right now.
Like, I gotta...
I swear, I feel like I...
I feel like I repeated the fourth grade, like, seven times.
Halima, it's not you.
I'm just on the edge right now, Halima.
I'm on the edge.
I've been repeating the fourth grade, like, seven times.
Like...
Oh my god.
This is the best... I don't wanna use... Okay.
I don't know.
I want...
This has to be the game.
I'm cheating.
I can't.
Okay.
Alright.
What did you say, Halima?
I can't.
I...
I'm doubting myself now.
I don't know.
I'm like, what if it is 2,000?
I was gonna pick false.
It has to be false, right?
Is it false, Halima?
Is it false?
The answer is...
False.
Oh my god.
I should've trusted my gut.
I should've trusted my gut, man.
I... Oh, I knew it was false, but then I'm like, it's so... Because it's such a specific answer.
When I become a doctor, I'm going to volunteer and travel the world.
With what money?
You need money for that, Halima?
It'd be like doctor money, but you're volunteering.
Okay, foreign language.
We're not testing social studies.
Social studies is geography.
It's spring.
It has to be spring.
Because that's where the flowers...
Wait, which one's spring?
Is it this one?
I assumed summer... I know these are summer, fall, winter.
So I was like, this has to be...
Why is it green?
Okay, it has to be spring.
Because that's where...
That's where it blossoms.
I was going to be like, what if it's not spring?
If I failed that one, that would be so sad.
The Sakura Blossom.
I've done Sakura Blossom stuff, so that would be so bad if I failed that.
What if it's not spring?
Okay, it's fifth grade.
Three more, guys!
Three more!
Goodbye, Halima.
Who is it?
Oh my god, Ava, let's go!
Ava, you can't disappoint me, right?
I no longer trust myself.
Okay.
Wait, she's good at...
Oh, I don't have foreign language yet anymore.
You know what?
I don't trust myself with reading.
Like, reading is like, here's a book that you've never read.
Like, it's a book you've never read.
I'm just like, I...
Romania?
That doesn't even exist.
Wait.
Bosnia and Herzegovina doesn't even fucking exist.
Wait, it does?
Didn't they disband it?
Wait, Bosnia and Herzegovina is still around?
I thought they disbanded.
Wait, am I thinking about a different place?
Wait, it still does?
It's...
I'm so sorry.
I'm so...
I was thinking about Yugoslavia.
Sorry.
I did not...
Sorry, Bosnians.
Bosnians.
I did...
I did not mean to say you're not real.
I didn't mean to say you weren't real.
I got confused.
I got so confused.
That is offensive.
We don't exist.
I'm so sorry.
You're real to us.
What the fuck is romance?
Is it?
Okay, I don't think it's Bosnia and Herzegovina because like I don't know.
It doesn't feel like it's a language.
It's either Romania and Switzerland.
I want to say Romania because it's romance.
Because it's like, oh yeah.
We Romanians here.
We speak romance.
We're not keeping time.
We could be in Switzerland because what the fuck do they speak over there?
Sorry.
I'm sorry to all the Swiss goons but what language do you guys speak there?
I don't even know what languages you guys speak there.
Like...
I don't like German is one of them because of Italian.
But truly what I learned about Europe is from Italia.
So like I know they speak German because of Italia.
So it's either Romania or Switzerland.
Okay.
They speak Swiss cheese of course.
Gam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Guys,
I don't claim Italia anymore.
Guys, guys, I'm reformed by the way.
I'm reformed from that.
I don't look at that past anymore.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I feel like...
Please.
I'm making me so nervous right now.
Okay.
Well.
We can't.
Okay.
We just need to answer two questions by ourselves.
Because 6th grade, we get no help.
So we might as well...
Oh my god.
Is it worth it?
Is it worth to cheat?
Oh, I feel like I should use the last 5th grade to cheat.
So it's either Romania or Switzerland.
I'm gonna flip a coin.
I'm gonna fucking flip a coin, guys.
Alright, I'm gonna... Okay.
Flip a coin.
Heads, it's Switzerland.
Tails, it's Romania.
It's heads.
Okay.
We got heads.
Alright.
We're relying on heads or tails.
And we got heads.
Okay.
Alright.
So in the end, it's not...
If we failed this, it's not me.
It's literally fake.
Alright, Switzerland.
We're gambling.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, thank god.
Thank you for the coin flip.
Thank you so much for the coin flip.
Oh my god.
Gambling paid off for once.
Oh, that's interesting.
I feel like translating stuff is really stressful in general.
So I'm not surprised.
Alright, spelling!
Let's go!
Oh my god, let's go!
Oh, it can't be that bad at spelling.
Guys, okay, I just needed a little time out there.
Okay.
Equipment.
Yes.
True.
I literally spelled it out.
I typed it out.
Equipment.
That has to be true.
Because like, it's E-Q-U-I-P-T-M Wait.
E-Q-U-I-P- M-E-N-T I almost spelled Equipment.
Equipment.
Unless it is spelled with a T.
E-Q-U-I-P- T-M-E-N- No, it's spelled with P. E-Q-U-I-P- M-E-N-T Okay, one.
One T.
Guys, I'm sorry.
This game is messing me up.
This game is actually messing me up.
It's true.
I'm getting really messed up right now.
Okay.
E-Q-U-I-P- M -E-N-T
E -Q-U-I-P- Oh, thank god.
I almost thought Equipment was spelled with two Ts for a sect.
I thought it was E-Q-U-I-P- T-M-E-N-T It almost got fucked over.
This game makes me...
Oh, this game.
This game does things to my brain.
Oh my god.
Goodbye.
Who would've thought?
We got rid of America and we start winning.
America no longer exists.
And then we figure it out how to play the game.
Okay.
Alright, vocabulary.
This is it.
No.
S-A...
S-A-L...
E...
Nameless!
It's nameless!
I know what anagram is!
I know it's when you rearrange the word and it becomes a different word with the same name!
Yes, I am smarter than a fifth grader!
Oh my god!
Oh me!
I did it!
Oh my god.
Oh, it's not clickbait.
It was not clickbait.
Oh my god.
I told you it wasn't clickbait.
Took me two hours, but we actually did it.
We graduated elementary school.
We're in middle school already.
I don't have to repeat the fifth grade.
Mike, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lord Kurosis, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Doki confirmed she isn't strong enough to survive the horrors of the American public school system.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
We just have to get rid of United States.
We just have to fucking dynostab them.
That's the only way.
The amount of times I got fucked over because of America.
I just had to turn this off.
I'm sorry.
It was the only way.
It was literally the only way to get out of there.
I didn't want to repeat school again, guys.
I'm sorry.
I just didn't want to repeat the grade.
So it's too old.
Anton, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Doki, looking forward to seeing you in Atlanta.
Have you been before?
Will you do 3AM Waffle House?
Do you know of... What the fuck is Okra?
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
No, I've never been to Atlanta, but I'll talk more about it in the superchat reading today.
I'm tired of this superchat reading today.
After successfully...
Another superchat.
Thank you.
After successfully graduating elementary school, I can confidently say that yes, I am smarter than a fifth grader.
As we all learned from HuniePop, it's not about the journey.
It's that it's the endgame.
I eventually made it through.
So in the end, I am smarter than a fifth grader.
We might have got rid of an entire country.
We might have got rid of several countries.
But in the end, we made it.
We learned what a kilogram is today.
And what...
We learned what a whole number is today as well.
We learned so many new things.
And I swear to God.
I swear to God.
I swear if I go up to a first grader and be like what the fuck is an aviation?
They won't know jack shit what aviation is.
Why would you teach a second grader to spell extraterrestrial?
What are they?
Some spelling bee champion?
They didn't even give me a sentence.
Are we doing the spelling bee?
In second grade, I did spelling classes in fifth grade and we didn't have a word for fucking extraterrestrial.
Like...
And I almost spelled equipment with two t's like that.
That was a little bit... But at that point my mind... At that point I was at that stage where... I was at that stage of mindset where like everything felt like not false.
Like everything in my life, I doubted.
Like I thought I was taught the wrong thing in my entire life.
Like...
I...
I was at the stage where I didn't know what's real and wasn't real anymore.
Like...
I just learned that salmon and tuna gives me mercury poisoning if I eat too much of it.
But like...
I eat a lot of salmon and tuna.
So like... I'm just like... I'm like...
Is my life like this because of salmon and tuna?
Like I feel like that should be like a more public concern than what it is.
Like...
Why did I have to learn now?
After X amount of years.
After since I was born.
Why did I have to learn that now?
Like 20 plus years is when I learned mercury poisoning occurs by eating fish.
Yet we don't give a shit.
We just keep eating.
Like...
I feel like that should be a more public knowledge thing than it was for me learning from a video game.
Okay.
Like now I have several new fears unlocked.
And the honey part too.
The honey part... The honey part was pretty fucked up.
Whoever... I don't even know.
Was it Ava?
Ava seemed to be like the one that kept giving me fucked up facts.
Like fucked up fun facts.
But like when Ava was like Fun fact!
You can die.
You can kill a baby with honey.
And I'm like Wait, what?
Like...
What do you mean you can...
A baby can die from that?
Like...
That wasn't fun at all.
That wasn't fun!
I didn't want to learn that!
Like...
Anyway...
We haven't been able to do super chat reading in a long time.
So today...
Today's our lucky day.
I won't be able to do all the super chats, but I'll try my best.
Also wanted to hang out with you guys for a little longer.
Alright.
By the way, did I successfully...
Did my honey pot vod successfully blurred?
Did I fully saved it?
It's still monetized too, by the way.
Like, the monetization is on.
Guys, okay, the craziest part about the honey pot stream is that...
Like...
It has 481 comments.
And then the stream before it was like 39 comments.
I... I...
It was a wild day yesterday.
It was...
It was a fucking wild day yesterday.
Um...
Alright.
Wait, because it was the last stream was the collab!
With...
With the Sloth Sisters.
I survived.
People had a lot of things to say about that stream.
Wait, I haven't went to the Super Chat category in a long time.
We haven't done Super Chat reading in so long.
I'm so sorry, everybody.
We've been so busy.
Um...
Seija, Nicholas, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm trying to remember which one I've read and which one I haven't.
Um...
Um... Because I, like, read Super Chats in between.
Wings, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just calling out chat like that.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Wings, thank you.
I mean, look!
My comments usually don't exceed 100 comments unless it's a very, like, a special event or anything.
But for some reason, not only did Honeypot Not only did Honeypot exceed 100 comments, we have 481 comments.
Oh, man.
But thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Medieval Doki Bird be like, why you fucking number?
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, I even cheated and, like, Hayley fucked it up.
I was like, I can't answer this.
I don't know what a whole number is.
Like, I'm getting paranoid on what a whole number was.
And I even asked Hayley.
I was like, Hayley, you should know.
You're literally in fifth grade right now.
You should know what a whole number is.
And then Hayley was like, three.
Like, you cannot blame me for that.
Like, Hayley was the one that fucked it up.
I thought it was, too.
But I was like, you know what?
I wanna make sure that I'm right.
So let me go ask Hayley.
Cause, like, she's literally in fifth grade.
I...
I was like, it has to be two.
But like, I was like, but what if I'm wrong?
Alright, Hayley.
I'm gonna make sure you double check my answer.
And then she was like, three.
What do you want me to do?
It wasn't even me at that point.
Like, what do I do at that point?
Hayley.
In my defense, I tried to cheat off a child.
And the child fucked me over.
The child was closer to first grade than I was.
Like, like, the child was closer.
Her age gap to first grade was closer.
So why does she not know what a whole number was?
Like, not so dead.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
According to DaddyYT, FNAF is raunchier than Honey Boy.
That's so true.
Wait.
My FNAF stream got...
My FNAF stream got R18 gated.
But yet, Honey Pot is still appropriate for all ages.
Like, I...
Like, okay.
We're in a little little oopsie here.
It was all horror, horror, horror, horror, horror, horror, and then it'll be funny if this guy's fucking gay.
I can't catch it.
Honey Pot more family-friendly than FNAF.
FNAF is literally my only um...
FNAF was like my only R18 stream I've ever had an 18 in...
18 years of streaming.
I mean, like, in the last 4 years of streaming as a VTuber, FNAF was literally the only stream I ever got R18.
Which is incredibly crazy to think about.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
OGPon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
As someone who has 100% both Honey Pot games, I sadly missed stream last night, but I hope you enjoyed the game.
Yeah...
Yeah, that...
I learned a lot yesterday.
I learned a lot today as well.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anton by Oshii.
I'm not a fail, girl!
I made it to the end of the journey.
The journey doesn't matter.
It's the end game.
And I made it to end game.
I saw people in chat being like, oh, Doki's not even gonna make it to the last date.
And I did.
I didn't even need you guys to ratatouille me on my head to try and like... I didn't even need you guys to ratatouille me, chat.
And I was able to succeed.
I freestyled 50% of those dates, guys.
I freestyled it.
After you guys yelled at me, I was like, I'm gonna freestyle now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My Oshii is a whole nother fail, girl.
Thank you for the super chat, Anton.
Thank you, thank you, Alan.
What's a kilogram?
When will kilogram ever be useful?
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Like, I use pounds!
I don't use kilograms!
I use pounds!
So often when?
In cooking?
I don't use kilograms in cooking!
Toki, you're not the American spirit.
Aren't you Canadian?
We have... No!
Okay!
No, guys, no.
Canada's actually really fucked up.
In Canada, we use pounds for just that.
Like, we use pounds, and then, and then, like, I don't know.
I don't know what's wrong with us, but...
I don't, I don't know.
No, in Canada, we actually use pounds!
so, so, it's a weird mixture.
It's like, it's a mixture of it.
Cause I remember talking to somebody in EU, I think I was, like, talking to, like, um, I was talking to, like, oh, I don't remember who.
It was, like, some fucking Apex player.
Uh, sorry, it's all blurring together.
And then, they were like, oh, yeah, it's, like, something kilogram.
And then, I was like, what the fuck is a kilogram?
I was like, I don't know what the fuck that is!
And then, and then he was like, oh, wait, aren't you Canadian?
And then, I was like, yeah, but, yeah, but we use pounds.
And then, he was like, what the fuck?
It's like, I was like, what the fuck?
So, we just, we use a mix!
We use pounds!
Like, I don't know what to say!
Like, that's what we, it's cause America's our neighbor!
And it, like, America's our neighbor, and it, like, mixed in.
Like, they, they infected us, like, with some of their stupid shit!
Like, with some of their, like, stupid measurements and shit!
Like, did you guys see that SNL, the only good recent SNL skit where they made fun of the American measurement system?
That, that's, like, legitimately like, um, one of the few good SNL skits they've done.
What was it?
Oh, yeah, Washington's Dream.
That was legit, that was pretty funny.
Um, what was it?
SNL measurement skit.
I'm gonna do Twitter.
Um, oh my God, you can do it at rfunny.
Let's fucking go.
SNL is cringe now, but, like, they actually had a, um, they had an actual good SNL skit, which is very surprising.
And it, it was talking about the same thing, which I'm SNL skit, George Walsh.
It's actually, actually pretty good.
Um, what's SNL?
Saturday Night Live.
It was legitimately, like, the only good skit they've ever done in, like, years.
Like, the only good thing they've done in so long.
I don't even know who's in the fucking cast anymore.
Um, other than, like, what's his name?
That one guy that will never leave.
Like, you know what I'm talking about?
That one guy who's gonna be in SNL for the rest of his fucking life.
Alright, here you go.
I think this is it.
Let me double-check.
I need to make sure my, my Chrome isn't.
There you go.
Kenan, yes!
The only SNL guy I know that's still there is Kenan Thompson.
He's never gonna fucking leave.
He's gonna die at SNL.
Like,
umm...
Um...
Let's see.
Uh, Wristwatch, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
RockTimer.
Superchat, thank you.
Zayn.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
We don't ratatouille you.
The potato... the tomato pilot.
The skin...
It's like a bunch of small tomatoes In my head right now within the tomato trying to figure out what the fuck to do.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not so deadpool.
You cried trying to use pounds in yesterday's stream.
Look, I didn't say I was good at measurements.
I just say that we use pounds like I fucking I don't remember majority of things I learned.
Like not so deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Lord Kurosis.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki hates kilograms and failed us.
I did not fail!
Repeating a grade does not mean I failed.
Like I still got past elementary school.
It might have taken me eight years too late, but like I still got past it.
We welcome her as an honorary American.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got held back.
That's different.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Loli, thank you for the super chat.
Look up the measure like a Canadian flow chart and show chat.
It is pretty accurate.
We used to use imperial.
Thank you for in the super chat.
Thank you.
Measure like a Canadian flow chart.
I don't think I've ever seen that.
I don't think.
What is this?
Canadian measurement flow chart.
What are you measuring?
The fuck?
What the fuck?
Is this how fucked up we are?
Is this what happens when we have like three countries trying to fucking take our country?
Guys, this is what happens when you had three countries trying to fucking be like you're mine Canada.
This is what happens.
Oh my god.
This shit is crazy to look at.
Like Like what are you measuring?
Distance.
Is it your height?
No.
Yes.
Metric.
Imperial.
Is it the pool's temperature?
Is it very heavy?
No.
Yes.
Is it your weight?
No.
Yeah, we use like pounds for weight.
And then is it for cooking?
No.
It's like what the fuck am I looking at?
Holy shit.
Cyber, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fun fact the Bosnian Herzegovina military to this day still use a tank from the 1960s.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The real G.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
In Doki's defense, even the UK uses mines.
So it makes sense.
So my mercury poison...
I'm just gonna blame it on the mercury poisoning.
Um
I'm just I'm just gonna I'm, now that I know that mercury poisoning is a thing I'm just gonna blame the fact that like salmon is like the national fish of Canada and I'm just gonna blame on the mercury poisoning I might not I don't know if I have it or not.
Like it's a good excuse now I'll be like Salmon is my national fish And could happen it didn't I don't know I never got tested
Um, then I never will Super thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you things.
I learned today my ocean.
I am not dumber I passed elementary school.
It might have taken me several years, but it still happened Not anything Um and easily gaslighted probably brain rotted by mercury and Canada measurements are weird.
Thank you with a super chat.
Thank you Thank you.
Um Oh, yeah, I'll show you guys the what was it Washington?
Uh, I'll show you guys the other one too the other Uh, George Washington skit, which was also pretty funny.
Oh this one.
This one's the other one.
This one was the original The original is the the the second one the one I think you guys was Uh the sequel to this skit, which is also pretty funny I was like this feels too real Um x thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait does mercury no Guys if it has poison guys if it has poison in the name it is not good for you Thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you no matter what guys if if it has um If it has point if the word poison is in there, it's not it does not mean you should do anything with
Okay, um, where was I on the super chats, uh Um Um alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Took you throwing hands of children live on stream Thank you super chat.
Thank you more than once surprisingly.
That's a pattern on my stream and I don't know why I don't know why i'm always i'm always challenging children like for some reason.
It's it's a very bad pattern Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you twice this week, by the way twice this week Um, it was neat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you as a romanian.
I was so ready to be offended But lady luck saved you from offending an extremely
I'm like, wow, there is a romania Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you I was like, what if they I know they speak romanian, but what if they also spoke a second language?
That's happened to be called romance I was like in my head.
I was like Let's start with roman Like it has the it has half of romania's letters Like it could have been Like it's an easy.
It was a very easy mistake guys.
It was it was a very easy mistake to make Thank you.
The super chat is me.
Thank you.
Aster.
The super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you The fifth grade was the best six years of jokey's life.
Thank you with a super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Um cad is singing the super chat.
Hey guys scientist here You don't want mercury in you unless you do who I am as a judge.
You're a scientist You should be making sure we don't have mercury in our system um Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, let's see uh Liam thank you a super chat.
Thank you So now might be the moment tell you to check the honey pop.
Oh my god, it's true.
No, don't say that.
No, i'm
Don't say that guys it doesn't exist guys guys Doesn't exist guys For the super chat Thank you marco.
Thank you the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Bye doki salmon has the least mercury of all fish sally.
That means we don't know read the tuna.
What about tuna?
Apparently I also eat a lot of tuna though But like it's not as much as salmon if I guess like if you add all all the salmon together We might have a little issue but like Like what happens if I mix salmon and tuna?
Oh tuna is the worst for okay Now we know Oh
Okay, um
Not as much as salmon though, it's not as much as salmon Oh, okay, that might be a little problem.
All right.
All right now Okay Let's pretend I didn't say that Like we have many fears that we unlocked today Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you a coyote.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um What a wild week guys, I don't know what I don't think I have much Um, I don't have a lot of stuff.
Uh Confirmed for next week.
Um, so it's gonna be it's gonna be i'm guess i'm gonna oh tomorrow I'm taking a rest day because i'm gonna go to Uh, I have a friend hanging out with me that's visiting me.
Um tomorrow so i'm super excited like, uh She's glad i'm staying over and stuff.
So like I gotta clean my apartment and like buy an air mattress for her because i'm like Like I sleep in like a doubles bed But like still like I figured it'd be more comfortable having like like an air mattress like their own area to sleep in and stuff and we're gonna go visit some if like it's um,
it's like Uh, yeah, my very I have no furniture too, by the way But we're gonna be we're just gonna be like hanging out and like, um, because it's almost halloween So there's a lot of halloween events going around too.
So like, uh tomorrow i'm gonna go outside.
I'm gonna hang out I'm, really excited because I normally, you know, I don't normally go outside Oh, I do go outside a lot now, but like nor like but it's mostly for business stuff So like i'm very excited to actually like go out and hang out with somebody because I don't do that very often I'm,
very I mean fucking i'm alive.
I'm a fucking vtuber streamer.
So like we don't really touching like, you know Meeting people outside of streaming is very rare.
So i'm super excited.
Um, so I haven't really planned much for next week Oh speaking.
I uh, i'm really also like I remember when I talked about you about animated stickers.
I'm super um, i'm super excited because uh Uh, they're almost done they're actually almost done now, um majority of them are almost fully animated Um, so I think we'll be done by next week and I cannot wait to release them next week Hey guys, by the way for those who don't know.
I also released my new halloween voice pack.
So please check it out Um, I actually wrote the whole entire script myself Um, and it comes with a very is with a free wallpaper.
So please if you want to support me, uh Check out my new my very first, uh official voice pack that I made I mean, there's the croaky one, but this is like the more formal official voice pack So please check out the halloween voice pack.
It comes with its own wallpaper.
I actually wrote the script myself um, I think this will be the only time I write the script myself and then like next i'll have like a script writer doing The future ones because I don't have time to write scripts myself.
So Um, so please purchase the voice pack if you can if you want to it really does help with funding future voice packs as well because you know, I um, I I Try to commission like really nice illustrations each voice packs can come with its own illustrations Coming for going forward.
So I try to do my best to like find a really nice artist to Have like a wallpaper to go, uh with it.
But yeah, hey guys i'm gonna head off now I'm, sorry.
I I know I was like i'm gonna read as much as I can that's as much as I can I Still need to rest my voice because i'm still coughing.
Um I'm still coughing a lot.
So, uh, i'm trying not to do too much talking Uh, just so I can you know, stop coughing because I still need to record stuff.
I still I still need to record things Um, but anyway guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that blood flowing And if you stay up for me head to bed guys, you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys Bye